hi everybody my name is Florian and
Yannick was nice enough to host him here
as a guest to talk about stochastic
earnings without teacher forcing this is
based on recent work deep state-space
models for unconditional word generation
which we presented at this year's new
ribs and if you like any more details
please check out the paper we focus on a
de facto standard training hack for any
ardennes that generate text
it's called teacher forcing and it's
used in any model whether unconditional
or conditioners such as in the sentence
auto encoder or in a translation model
to understand where teacher frozen comes
from we first need to understand where
text generation comes from for the good
or the bad and here we will focus on the
bad the text generation has its roots in
language modeling so language modeling
is the problem of predicting the next
word given all the previous words people
used to use angra models for this but to
tape people use recurrent neural
networks to do that
such recurrent neural networks or RNAs
factorize the joint observation
probability of a sequence that I hear
depicted W into independent softmax
distributions over individual tokens so
for every time step there's a software's
function and the softmax is conditioned
on a hidden state and all the magic of
the RNN goes into the function that
gives you the new state given the old
hidden state usually this is called a
transition function f and as an input it
gets the last state and the last word so
f could be a GU function on Alice TM
function just like any other language
small you can turn this into a
generative model of text let's look at
the dependencies that you would have a
test time there's an initial hidden
state h1 we sample a new word we use our
transition function f and gives us the
new state h 2 then we can sample a new
word w2 feed it back at a new state
simply a new word feed it back it's
important to note that all the
stochasticity in the output
is solely due to the stochasticity in
the sampling process because the
transition function is deterministic so
far there's nothing to complain about
but so far I've only talked about test
time a training time there is a catch
this is where teacher forsen kicks in it
turns out that you can't learn this
model by basing the evolution of the
hidden states on your own predictions
you have to use teacher forcing and that
means you substitute your own
predictions by the ground choose so a
training time there's no sampling loop
you just take the ground truth token and
feed it into your state transition
function so that feels unintuitive
because at test time we do something
else then we do a training time it's
also known in the literature for a few
years to cause biases so why is that
problematic remember we come from
language modeling announced modeling we
could argue that if our only goal is to
predict one word given the previous
words then of course we can use the
ground truth context to ground truth
previous words but if we're interested
in generating like longer sequences then
we need to learn what to memorize and in
particular we need to become robust
against our own predictions because we
might make mistakes at test time and
there's no ground truth at test time
just to get this confirmed by somebody
who is worked in the field for years at
the new rips for presentation learning
workshop Alex Grave mentioned teacher
forcing and as one of the big three
problems for auto regressive models and
in his own words TV or forcing might
lead to predict one step ahead not many
and potentially brittle generation in
myopic representations half people
address teacher forcing so far their
approaches to try to mitigate a problem
for example by blending together these
two views training time and test time so
that sometimes you use your own
prediction you're in training but
sometimes you use to grant truce we
believe for a rigorous model of text
generation we need a rigorous model of
uncertainty this should be an integral
part of any generative model and
therefore it should be the same model
both a training time and test time
without any hacks we propose a
fundamentally different approach by
proposing a new transition function the
new transition function is non auto
regressive
that means it depends on the last stage
HT minus one but it doesn't depend on
the last word that means teacher forcing
is not an option anymore but it also
means teacher forcing is not a problem
anymore instead to transition function
accepts a white noise vector as the
second input now you might wonder why do
we need noise at all as an input to the
transition function well for given
prefix there might be different
continuations so we need some source of
entropy to model the entropy in
different continuations the rest of the
paper pretty much focuses on the
following two questions a which function
f is powerful enough to turn the most
simple noise source just a standard
Gaussian vector into something that's
powerful enough to replace the
autoregressive feedback mechanism of a
standard Arnon the second question is of
course how do we train this what
framework to be trained this in and it
will turn out that variation of flows
are suitable functions F and variational
inference is the right wing framework to
train them so here's the road map to
complete the model first we need to cast
the genitive model as a probabilistic
method because so far I've only sketched
a procedure that involves sampling some
noise and then applying some function
and then predicting observations then we
need to propose a variation of inference
models so that we can do maximum
likelihood training we will derive an
elbow which is our objective then in the
paper we also describe how the tightness
of the elbow can be improved and here I
will finish by talking a bit about
evaluation and what we do to inspect the
model since this work is based a lot on
variational flows let me give you a
quick summary or variation of flows a
rational flow is deform or fizzing F
which maps from what I would call a
simple Norton space X I to a complex
noise space H and here I'm already using
the notation for a sequence model simply
by the change of variable formula we
know that the probability of an event H
in the complex space is simply the
probability of the event in the simplest
basic sigh as given by the inverse of F
times AJ
in terms respect to F evaluated at sign
how can we use this in our sequential
setting first let me fix some notation
because sequential models are pretty
prone to overloaded notation all right
time as T around running from 1 to
capital T and whenever I talk about a
sequence of variables like W I don't
index them I just write W without an
index and only when I need a specific
element I'll write it as W T let's
formalize the generative model we start
out with a probability of observing a
sequence W and since we use the latent
variable model we marginalize out the
latent variables H and then we will
assume that the overall dependencies
between hidden States H and observations
W follow like an hmm type of dependency
that means the new state only depends on
the last state and the current
observation only depends on the current
state and now the question is how do we
model these transitions I've so far
pitched the ideas of sampling noise and
then using some transition function f
and we've seen flows already now we are
ready to combined it to we proposed a
transition function f G which has the
signature as I mentioned before it gets
a hidden state and a noise phase vector
as an input and it gives you a new state
as an output this can be seen as a
conditional flow because any h t minus 1
any last state inserted as the first
argument into F G and uses a flow which
maps from the simple noise distribution
to the space of new hidden States and as
I've said before for the prior
distribution in the simple noise space
we simply assume it's a standard
Gaussian
let's look at this graphically because
in the end this is a graphical model I
copied over the formulas from the last
slide and at the bottom you see the
graphical model first we have a sequence
of stochastic variables X I those
deterministically induce via the
transition function f fired a flow a
sequence of hidden states and those
independently predict the observations
all the magic is in a transition so let
me sketch this process here in the big
circle how do we get from the last state
h2 to the new state h3 let's say h2
encodes the prefix and there are two
possible combinations they're equally
likely in the corpus so there are two
potential new states the blue state h3
and the yellow stage h3 I've sketched
the standard Gaussian noise distribution
at the top there yellow samples and
their blue samples the flow realizes a
mapping that takes any yellow sample and
maps it to the yellow hidden state and
its maps any blue sample to the blue
hidden state so with probability 1/2 in
this situation we either get a blue or a
yellow sample from the simple noise
distribution and it will G induce new
States blue h3 or the yellow h3 so far
we have proposed the generative model
now the question is how do we train it
if you don't know the hidden States the
answer is rational inference and in
particular
amortised variational inference the key
idea of variation inference is to
introduce a parametrized approximate
inference model how do we propose such a
model well a good recipe is to first
look at a true posterior the probability
of a state sequence given an observation
sequence the true posterior turns out to
factorize into individual components
which give us the probability of a state
given the last state and the future
observations it turns out that we can
formulate this inference model using two
ingredients that should be familiar
first we use a transition function
FQ which induces a flow it has the same
signature as FG for the generative model
and we use a noise source Q but now the
noise source isn't uninformative anymore
in variation inference the inference
network is a form Tabata data so there's
a base distribution Q of excit which is
allowed to look at the data WT now
compared is to teach you forcing and
teacher forcing we substitute our own
predictions by inserting ground truth
information into the generative model
and very
it's very clear how to use the data the
data enters through the inference model
it enters in the form of future
observation because the past observation
we want to store in the hidden state it
remains to derive an elbow which is the
usual evidence law about objective used
for racial inference any elbow whether
it's in a sequential setting or not
factorizes into two parts a
reconstruction loss and a model mismatch
term here reconstruction loss means
probability of an observation giveness
state and modern mismatch is between the
genitive model P and the inference model
Q this is what is usually written as a
KL divergence to derive our elbow we
follow the literature on flaws in a
first step we introduced a flaw on the
influence model FQ we turn the
expectation with respect to the complex
state space age into an expectation with
respect to the simple noise distribution
and then of course at the same time the
flow appears inside the expectation and
we cut the lock determinant in terms
that I've mentioned before in a second
step we introduce the generative flow FG
using the same change of variable
technique it's possible to write out the
elbow in a way so that has only one
Jacobian term for both flows and so that
the genitive model always appears as the
inverse concatenated with the influence
flow in a second I'll show you what the
imputation of that is let's quickly
recap what we've seen so far
there's a generative model it consists
of a genitive flow F G and an uninformed
noise source there's an inference model
which contains at inference flow F Q and
a simple based distribution across the
noise variables Q of X I in the elbow
the two flows appear concatenated and we
can interpret this in the following way
the infants model Q proposes a noise
vector excit that is informed about the
future the infants flow maps this two
hidden state at the hidden state the
reconstruction loss lives this is where
we pay a price for making a bad
prediction hi
the infants model cannot encode all the
possible information about the future
into the hidden state HT because the
mapping continues to the simple noise
base of the genitive model and the
inference model must make sure that the
proposal also covers significant
probability mass under the uninformed
prior this trade-off between
reconstruction and model mismatch is
common to all elbows but here we
highlight a special situation where we
have two flows one for the infant's
model in one fine general model in our
paper we also show how we can use the
recently proposed important bladed
autoencoder
to improve the tightness of our bond but
I'll skip those steps here instead let's
quickly talk about evaluation we apply
our model to unconditional generation so
why in hell would somebody look into an
unconditional generation well actually
it turns out it's harder than
conditional generation if you know what
the French sentence looks like it's much
easier to continue a partial English
translation but it's not only harder
it's also more interesting to inspect
which information doesn't sequence model
need to store and which information
cannot forget we use two metrics to
evaluate our model first we look at
sequence cross-entropy
so we compare the model's sequence
distribution to the data sequence
distribution usually estimating the data
distribution is impossible you don't
want to say that the probability of a
sentence is how many times the sentence
has appeared in the training data
however for words we can use unigram
frequencies of words in a corpus as a
pretty reliable estimate also we can get
an estimate of our models probability
assigned to a sequence by using MC
sampling we take the marginal likelihood
sample k trajectories and assess the
probability that the trajectories
assigned to the given sequence since our
model is not autoregressive
the sequence isn't tied to an
observation so we can actually use the
same sequences of hidden states to
evaluate probabilities for all the words
in the vocabulary since we've pitched
our noise model as the kitra
contribution to our generative model we
want to empirically verify that the
model is being used working with a clean
probabilistic model allows us to use
tools from
ability Seri to assess that we use the
mutual information between a noise
vector at time T and the observation of
time T so this measures how much
information in the output is actually
due to the noise model before showing
you the numbers let's quickly go across
the province digitization of our model
for the flows we look at shift scaling
transformations and if the scaling GE is
lower triangular we can compute
efficiently the Jacobian determinant we
also look at real MVP and we compose
flows by concatenation the based
distribution of our infants model
depends on the future observations which
we summarized using a GI u RN n the
based distribution itself is a diagonal
Gaussian we use a state size of 8 and
also run some experiments for 16 and 32
all the numbers are in the paper so here
are just two take-home messages we on
par or better than atomistic are an N
for teacher forcing train at the same
state size also we observed it a
powerful generative flow is essential to
achieve good performance furthermore we
can confirm that important point is
elbow improve the results this the first
model employing genitive flows to
sequence modelling so naturally we are
interested in comparing the
expressiveness of F G and F Q our paper
has a table that compares four choices
for post flows our findings are that the
genitive flow should be powerful and the
infants flow should be slightly less
powerful to understand our noise model
we look at the mutual information at
every time step and show a boxplot for
all of them initially the mutual
information is highest which means the
initial character is most important to
remember the noise model is never being
ignored and we see increased variance in
the remaining time steps because we are
averaging here across different
sequences the non autoregressive model
needs to have lower entropy in the
observation model because any under
entropy under the observation model is
being forgotten because there's no
feedback the Purple Line shows you the
observation model entropy during
training the dashed red line shows you
the entropy on the observation model of
a baseline so indeed
we have lower entropy in observation
model and at the same time in green is
the Demeter information increasing
let's summarize our findings using
rational flows none other aggressive
modeling of sequences is possible and
teacher forcing is not necessary at the
same time we get a noise model that is a
driving factor of the sequence model and
is easy to interpret for any details
please check out a paper and find any
questions shoot me an email